présidente député et homme d'affaires
rustème numérov devrait prochainement
devenir ministre de la Défense ukrainien
négociateur aguerri il avait notamment
obtenu un accord avec la Russie sur
l'exportation de céréales
devrait diriger le ministère
le Parlement ukrainien le connaît très
bien et Monsieur humérus n'a pas besoin
de recommandations supplémentaire
j'attends que le Parlement soutienne ce
candidat l'automne sert à se renforcer
gloire à l'Ukraine
au Lexy Reznikov ministre de la Défense
en exercice avait été nommé en novembre
2021 quelques semaines avant le début de
la guerre il sait notamment illustré
dans les négociations avec les
puissances étrangères pour obtenir une
aide militaire mais le ministère de la
Défense a récemment été accusé de passer
des commandes de matériel surfacturés
plaçant Reznikov au cœur de la tourmente
ce changement annoncé par Zelenski est
aussi perçue comme une tentative de
relancer la contre-offensive ukrainienne
qui a commencé au début de l'été